[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'd
be fine without me hello everybody
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua fields Milburn my
friends call me our dog but you can call
me Ryan Nicodemus and together we are
the minimalists never called you our dog
well you should hello everybody welcome
to episode 65 today's episode is called
tour we're gonna talk about touring but
really we're gonna talk about some of
the the routines while we are on the
road some of our favorite places to go
on the road we're gonna talk about
travel and how we pack for tours and
we're going to talk about the less is
now tour as well so Ryan you and I just
announced the less is now tour this
podcast is going up on Thursday which is
during the pre-sale period we wanted to
give our audience the first crack at
getting the best seats in the house
before they go on sale to the general
public so if you're listening to this on
Thursday March 9th 2017 you have less
than 24 hours to get your presale
tickets using the code minimal over at
the minimalists comm slash tour and if
you go there that that basically just
means that you'll have access to the
best seats there's also we're doing some
of them with we're doing many of the
events we're doing VIP events beforehand
so not only do you get the best seats
but we're gonna spend 45 minutes before
the event with a small group of people
working out some new material asking
some questions having some discussions
with people and we're working on some
some special side projects that we're
only gonna share with a few handfuls of
people a few dozen people in each city
and then we'll have the larger
presentation of being on tour as well so
when we hit the road for this tour it's
going to be larger theaters for the most
part but we're going to give a talk
about minimalism we have a brand new
presentation
we're working in some old material some
new material and we're recording a live
version of the podcast we're doing a
version of ask the minimalists will
answer your questions will dish out free
hugs to anyone who sticks around
afterward and if some of these we're
even going to film the events as well so
we can have some video footage to use
later for different stuff which will
which would be really fun but I wanted
to go today I want to talk about
different cities that were going to Ryan
maybe talk about some of our experiences
if we have a limit if we're limited in
the city if we have only one day like
what one of the some of the things that
we do we can talk about that and we can
also talk about some of our our travel
routines what we've learned from many
many failures over the years of of
touring so we should where do we start
we must want to talk about the cities
were going to first um yeah let's do
that alright cool so let's see I'm
pulling up the minimalists comm slashed
or joined the minimalist for a night of
Les Joshua and Ryan will blah blah blah
he said that presale tickets are now on
sale which means our audience gets the
best access use code minimal okay here
it is we are going we're starting the
tour in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania we
haven't been there since 2014 we of
course he's up there I think that was
our exact midpoint was Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania was the midpoint of that
crazy hundred city tour we did back in
2014 really love Pittsburgh man yeah I
do too it reminds me a lot of Cincinnati
even though I know their football teams
hate each other well it's funny cuz I
was gonna say like it took me forever to
like actually love Pittsburgh uh-huh
like we would go there to see some
concerts when we work together right and
then went there on tour I think the
first time we went was 2011 yeah it was
and I think that was the first time I
was like dude Pittsburgh doesn't suck
just because you hate the Steelers put
that in context you're Cincinnati
Bengals fan yeah which is which is the
only worse football team to be a fan of
is the bills which I am also a fan of
yeah ha so so I'm not like bragging on
the Bengals by any stretch but yeah
there is that rivalry there and it is
it's so funny to me though how like I've
let it go now because I just don't put
my heart in the football like or the
over my emotion in the football I guess
yeah as much as I used to yeah but it is
funny though like when you are in in
into it with a team yeah like you do get
this disdain for the rivals and like any
fan of theirs it's like you have this
like automatic I hate you the same way
Michael Jordan still makes my like blood
boil a little bit when I hear a news
because I I'm the only person I know
from Dayton Ohio who was a Utah Jazz fan
and not just like a little bit of a Utah
Jazz I mean John Stehr I still believe
John Stockton is the greatest basketball
player of all time he does leading the
he's still he's in a three five three of
the five to the five yeah so he has most
steals of all time and most assists and
there's not anyone who's even close to
beating his assist record and I think it
steals records pretty far off as well
and you look at the people who were
second in those categories I think the
the the second on steals list Michael
Jordan second on assists Magic Johnson
and there may be other people who have
displaced the second place person but
John Stockton in my opinions greatest
basketball player of all time didn't he
wasn't he coaching like a kids team out
in Bozeman was sort of his daughter was
going to Montana State College yeah yeah
and so he was the assistant coach last
year the greatest basketball player of
all time was the assistant coach at
Montana State University in Bozeman
Montana
he lives in Spokane which is relatively
close to us he's from Spokane with the
Gonzaga anyway those so here's how much
I love the Utah Jazz 1998 this is second
Finals that they're in they got beat the
previous year by the Bulls game six
Jordan hits that last minute shot at the
buzzer over Brian Russell who he
actually fouled Brian Russell that's
yeah but they no one tells you about
this he pushes Brian Russell I and then
and then steps back takes that shot and
you see the shots on all the posters
it's his last shot of his NBA career
until he came back and played for like
the Wizards or whatever but it was his
last shot of that that chunk of his
career you know 23 Jordan and he fouled
Brian Russell and then takes that shot
wins the game I haven't watched a full
NBA game since Game six of 1990
NBA Finals so yes I understand your
disdain for for that but guess what I
don't hate the city of Chicago and I
don't actually hate Michael Jordan I do
recognize in the news I think if one of
the most Super Bowls out of any football
team actually so if my disdain is
anything it comes from my own
insecurities and I'm just like
projecting that yeah plus I recognize
that Michael Jordan's the second best
basketball player of all time after that
were you know we've been the 48 states
while touring and there's two states we
haven't been so we have not been to
Alaska and we've not been to Vermont but
will not be able to say that soon
because we're coming to Burlington
finally because we're going to Anchorage
Anchorage Vermont Anchorage Alaska no
we're not
oh we're not going to Anchorage I hope
to get there that's nice though oh we're
going to Burlington Vermont
that's on April 14th in April 15th we're
going to Boston that one's already going
to sell out so if you are in anywhere
near Boston if you're in Rhode Island or
wherever else make sure you get your
tickets is a huge theater the Wilbur
theater there in Boston but that one's
gonna sell out with that one went on
sale a little bit earlier that was the
first one we announced and then after
that we're headed to Portland Portland
Maine one of my favorite cities love
that town you know I'm gonna need so
many lobster rolls between Boston in
Portland you think they have a lobster
in Burlington probably not yeah I'm sure
they do everywhere now but yeah it's
close enough to Crete me all of your
best lobster roll place recommendations
the best place I've eaten at so far in
Shawn podcast wasn't McDonald's and
Halifax can attest to this
you shut your mouth when you're talking
to me we we went to a place called
Luke's Lobster it's like a small chain
in New York yeah and it's by far like
the best lobster rolls we went there in
Maryland Reese I'm not trying to brag
but I've probably had over a hundred
lobster rolls in my life and
Luc's lobsters by far the best so if you
got a lobster roll recommendation hit me
up on twitter at Ryan Nicodemus all
right before we move on to the next wave
so that's our first wave of this first
leg so the let's talk about how we're
doing this so the first leg is nineteen
cities it is basically now through June
and then we're gonna take you to the
month of July off all together but we're
going out for three or four cities in a
row so it's just a long weekend because
you and I have learned lessons from
being on the road when we did the crazy
100 City tour in 2014 we were on the
road for 10 months and that takes its
toll for sure we don't want to do that
again so what we're gonna do we're just
going out for a long weekend basically
and we will go out to those for three or
four cities in a region and we're
calling that a wave a wave of of the
tour and so thing a thing that I like to
do to get a good sense of a city find
the best coffee house in town so if you
have a great coffee house recommendation
make sure you tweet us at the
minimalists or you can tweet me at JM
we're at Ryan Nicodemus we'd love to
hear your coffee house recommendations
but also I love going to an art gallery
or museum and see like what's going on
in that City via the the artistic
perspective of the city also quite often
we're on tour we go to independent
bookstores but I because we're speaking
a lot of independent bookstores we're
not doing that this time we're doing
fairly large theaters this time around
but if I get a chance I'll also be going
to some of my favorite in the book shops
in a lot of these cities and I think
those are nice little hubs for the city
what else Ryan what else do we do when
we're in a city that that's about it MIT
coffee a coffee bookstore museums hide
food yeah I was gonna say as some kind
of ethnic food even like because so it
was Thai food but I'm thinking of like
because we don't have great Indian food
or Thai food in Missoula Montana now or
Ethiopian food I mean like the old
Bessie I mean yeah like Beck's will cook
some amazing Ethiopian food or like some
of the refugees will make me meals but
like you can't go to a restaurant and
get good Ethiopian food so yeah
Thai food or like even Indian cuz like I
know how much you hate Indian food so
when you find an Indian food place that
you like yeah it's like a pretty damn
awesome
maybe we try that out this time around
we'll find the best Indian food places
yeah that will find the India food place
I hate the least yes actually
I love some Indian food it's just I
don't like the way it makes my clothes
smell and I'm really sensitive to smells
yeah but yeah I think Thai food does the
same thing to my clothes though so
what's that Indian place in in Provo
that's like the best Indian place ever
yeah it is it is truly great Provo Utah
it is Bombay house I think it's a Bombay
house it might be I don't know anyway
yeah so there's great Indian food in
places you wouldn't expect because when
I think of Provo Utah I think Indian
food no not at all and by the way we're
not going to Provo this time although we
did that year or so I'm just throwing
that out there in case you ever passing
through Provo or if you live in Provo
you probably already know of course you
know yeah for sure all right let's let's
take a look here next wave we're calling
this the north so that was the Northeast
wave the next wave we're going to the
northwest so we're going to Missoula and
then we're going to Spokane and Seattle
and Portland Oregon so that's the other
Portland we're going coast-to-coast
Portland - Portland wave to wave there
so missoula we're gonna be the Denison
theater it's a big theater at the
University Montana if you're anywhere in
Montana and you you're thinking about
coming to see us this is going to be
your one chance because generally we
don't do a lot of talks in in our
hometown and this is a good opportunity
for for you to come out and say hi and
and listen to us talk and also help us
fill this theater because it's a massive
place Gosei it's crazy like when we do
events in Missoula it's it's always
people like not always but the vast
majority of people who come are not from
Missoula they live in Casper or like
they yeah or they live in somewhere in
Idaho huh yeah it's like the closest
that will ever be to them yeah yeah yeah
no I do love doing talks in our hometown
yeah so so come on out to that Missoula
talk or Spokane that's the closest big
city to where we are we'll be in Spokane
the very next day May May 10th then
we're gonna be in Seattle and Portland
really looking forward to both of those
we have great audiences in both cities
and of course those are like the
back-to-back coffee mecca's I'm gonna be
so freaking calf and
I would ask you what your favorite part
of the Pacific Northwest is and oh
that's my answer is less sushi there's
sushi in and Seattle is off the main man
I don't think I've ever had sushi in
Seattle there's this place in Bellevue
I've got to take you to man
I am blanking on the name if you go to
Yelp and just type in sushi Bellevue
Washington you'll see the place with the
chirashi Bowls yeah oh yeah I want one
right now that we don't have any sushi
here where we are but every time we have
sushi no this is Josh no yo I just want
I just want all of our listeners out
there to know that cans of sardines hey
sushi listen lady no I just want all of
our listeners to know that in Missoula
Montana we live in the city of almost we
have Indian food and it's almost amazing
we have Thai food it's almost like the
best Thai food oh I wouldn't say the
best but it's almost like you know hits
the spot
same thing with sushi it's like they'll
have like these amazing dollar sushi
nights and there is some like if you
make sure to get like a couple like the
yellowfin tuna and like the egg row if
you like that type of stuff or not a
grow just the ROE roll in row but no
they do have the egg I forget what it's
called though it's called something
different yeah but anyway there's like
two or three things you can get that do
hit the spot but for all intensive
purposes like you can't just go there
and get awesome sushi so I don't want to
like totally bash the restaurants we do
have we do have some options but yeah
manned or definitely some better options
once you get closer to the coast right
my favorite restaurant in Missoula is
minimal wellness.com thankfully Beck's
is the best cook I've ever met and so my
partner like seriously like it is my
favorite restaurant in all of Montana is
to just has that your kitchen table yeah
I mean Beck's makes did she made some
awesome Ethiopian stuff the other night
she made her halibut is just
unbelievable I got a you gotta come over
sometime when she's making halibut it is
says yeah it's just it's so good so
anyway that restaurant is not open to
the public anyway we're then the next
wave we're headed to the up
Midwest Grand Rapids Chicago Madison and
Minneapolis we haven't been to any of
these cities of Chicago since 2014 Grand
Rapids that's the only city we're doing
in all of Michigan so if you're in
Detroit you're in Ann Arbor you're in
Saginaw you're in Lansing you're an East
Lansing you're in Flint you're in
Pontiac come on over to Grand Rapids
we'd love to see you there we could I'd
love to make you know someday I want to
do a tour Orion it's where everywhere
we've never been so one of our favorite
artists Austin Hartley Leonard he has an
album or an EP caught it's with that
song Ohio on it
it's called everywhere I've never been
man I would love to do a tour of lay all
right now we're gonna do a tour stop in
Saginaw and now we're gonna do a tour
stop in and College State what's uh
what's what's the city in the middle of
Pennsylvania College I have no idea yeah
anyway am i right Sean yeah he's he's
he's nodding his head
suspiciously or like I want to go to
Mobile Alabama or I want to go really
really we haven't done a stop there's
Detroit yeah yeah I know we haven't and
it just didn't work out with this leg
unfortunately we were trying to book
Detroit I was working with Andrew or a
booking agent by the way I got to say
thanks to him and thanks to Nicole over
at APA our booking agency this first
time we've worked with a booking agent
in the past Ryan and I would just be
like at the kitchen table together
calling up the news so yeah so talking
about lessons we've learned oh man yeah
well let's get to that let's hold that
hold that thought please put it in your
steel trap Ryan and we'll come back to
it yeah so we'll be in Madison
Minneapolis we have great audiences and
both of those cities I think we'll get
good turnouts but by the way if you're
in Milwaukee we weren't able to do
Milwaukee so if you're in Milwaukee
either come down the Chicago or come on
over to Madison same with if you're
anywhere else in Minnesota Minneapolis
is is the place to go right because
we're gonna be there for one night on
May 21st and then and that's a medium
sized venue so that one I mean most of
these will sell out relatively quickly
so if you're thinking about getting
tickets now is the time to do it while
they're on presale and you have access
to them before the general public
because once a live nation puts it out
there and once Ticketmaster puts it out
there these places are gonna sell out
and I just well I just wanna warn you
about that after that that wave that
Upper Midwest way which we're going
there at a good time Ryan late May for
the Upper Midwest is like spring is
bringing yeah like when people like
don't like spring I love spring yeah I
did too so you said Missoula is the the
city of almost like we have April and we
have May which is almost spring in
Missoula but it's still kind of winter
you know what that's the one thing we
don't have it's it actually is amazing
is the snowboarding we have there is no
almost like this is yeah I love this
spot for snowboarding anyway for sure
yeah okay so after that we're going back
back back to Cali Cali yeah you got it
Shawn you know where you got a do Cool
J's back to Cali yeah we are going back
to Cali we have three cities and on the
Cali wave in June we're gonna do San
Diego one of my favorite cities Los
Angeles which might be my favorite city
in the world and in San Francisco
another one of my favorite cities we try
to do Sacramento it just didn't work out
in terms of timing and the venue didn't
work out for us so if you're in
Sacramento would you please be willing
to make the 90 minute drive down to San
Francisco we'll make it worth your while
I also you know I love Sacramento Ryan I
think it's like the most slept on town
maybe it's not in America certainly in
California it reminds me of a Midwest
it's like Minneapolis but with
outstanding weather and so I really dig
I really dig Sacramento sadly I don't
get to go there this time and neither do
you Ryan because but we're gonna be in
three coastal cities San Diego Los
Angeles and San Francisco June 11th 16th
and 18th respectively I'm so looking for
there's been an extra like three or four
days there in Los Angeles I'll take you
over to the to the Russian bath houses
while we're there the cold plunge we
will do the cold plunge we will do
cryotherapy while we're there we will
explore Griffith Park will explore all
there is food yes I was gonna say no LA
Lake that's when I think of like the
best sushi I've had in the country yes
Sean the first time he ever had sushi
forget the name of the place it's in a
strip mall no no we're
and it was like it was unbelievable it
was just melting in my nose on Santa
Monica Boulevard but that's like such a
long it's the whole city so yeah come on
out and see us those will all sell out
for sure relatively decent sized venues
but we have great audiences there and
then the last wave of this first leg
we're gonna be back in the Midwest back
on our old stomping grounds these are
four cities that I would go to concerts
in and all the time so Ryan and I living
in Dayton Ohio we were two hours from
all of these four cities Indianapolis or
actually Columbus as well before they
I'm sorry Cleveland was before us but
Indianapolis Cincinnati Columbus
Cleveland you know it's plenty driving
from Cincinnati Cleveland uh-huh like
that three or three and a half hour
drive I hate I just like hate dreaded
uh-huh that Drive yes but it's fun it's
it's funny cos here in Missoula like to
get the glacier it's three hours you get
anywhere from Missoula
I love driving and because it's so
beautiful yeah we're like in Ohio it's
like strip malls and it's just flat it's
in fatica Lee flat in corn and corn corn
yeah there's a who's that mark Lehner
mark Lehner was describing driving
through the Midwest and one of his short
stories and the opening page of it was
corn corn corn barn
corn corn where is the Corn Palace at
that's in South Dakota that's more of
like a corn High School a great
experience a great novelty experience
that you will regret but you'll enjoy
regretting it okay so the Corn Palace is
really just a hold like a band in high
school with corn taped to the side of it
it's like it's like they just renamed
flea market and put a bunch of corn
decorations ever it's not so much a
palace it's it's it's just corn all
right yeah it's in the middle of South
Dakota which we will not be in South
Dakota but but stay tuned
all right so Indianapolis Cincinnati
Columbus Cleveland Indianapolis is the
largest venue so this is so cool I used
to go to concerts at the Egyptian room
to see like Ray LaMontagne we're gonna
be speaking at the Egyptian room how
awesome is that awesome and we're gonna
be a Bogaerts in Cincinnati I've seen
countless concerts at Bogaerts in
Cincinnati and now we get to go talk
about minimalism at Bogaerts and I just
feel great about that so Columbus
Cleveland come out and see us we're
looking forward to seeing you that's the
end of that first leg and then if you go
to the minimalists calm slash tour you
can see we're working on 28 potential
cities now these cities may change based
on venue availability but subscribe to
our email list that way you can be the
first to know about upcoming events so
here are some potential cities we might
come to in August through December so we
might hit Canada Saskatoon Edmonton
Calgary Vancouver Montreal Ottawa other
was one of my favorites house
yeah me too how solid are we on these
cities that we might like if you give me
a percentage well I mean for any we're
definitely gonna be going to some of
them the question is yeah I mean it's
just hard to book a tour right and so
these are decisions were trying to book
right now if I had to guess of these
twenty-eight will be somewhere between
twenty to twenty five of them okay and
then from there Ottawa and Toronto and
Winnipeg so that's what eight nine
cities throughout Canada we're gonna try
to hit in August to September which is
by the way the best time to be in Canada
August and September and then from there
we're gonna hit the East Coast New York
City Philadelphia Washington DC those
are the three cities were trying to hit
on the East Coast the in that area and
then from there the Mountain States Salt
Lake City one of our best cities for
turnout is surprisingly Salt Lake City
we just have a lot of people who really
resonate with our message there in Utah
so we're gonna try our best to get back
to Salt Lake and Denver and Albuquerque
which I've not been to in many years and
I love Albuquerque one of my favorite
cities a lot of our documentary
minimalism was filmed in Albuquerque
actually and let's see here and we I
haven't been wow I haven't been to
Albuquerque since the tour since since
we filmed the documentary and since that
tour me too Wow yeah and then Phoenix
after that huge city huge crowds there
that'll be great back to the Midwest st.
Louis Kansas City and
gonna try to get all three of those
cities and then we're headed the South
Houston Austin Dallas Oklahoma City
haven't been to any of those places
except Dallas since 2014
Louisville Nashville
Charlotte Birmingham Alabama Atlanta and
Tampa these are all cities we're gonna
try to get to and then of course yes
what about Australia what about Europe
and Asia and South America and Africa
Antarctica yeah yeah sure and and and
the 8th continent Alaska I would totally
do we should like at some point we
should do an Inc was it killable we went
to every country or no we're not going
every country no not every country I
know I could never talk you in every
country but we could do every continent
and we could totally do something in
Antarctica man so I know we have I know
at least we have one listener out there
in Antarctica so let's just talk about
this if all goes well in North America
we would love to take the lessons now
tour to your country to your continent
maybe even to Antarctica
so yeah sign up for our email newsletter
list over at the minimalists calm and
you'll be the first to hear about the
new events now the reason you couldn't
get me to go to every country Ryan this
is a good segue here is there are three
things that I hate I hate travel
I hate large crowds of people and I hate
public speaking now
I don't actually hate those things those
things make me uncomfortable especially
traveling makes me uncomfortable in fact
traveling by itself I find no appeal in
at all we have one of our best friends
is a guy named Colin right world
traveler travels to a new country over
four months
he loves traveling everything he does
centers around travelling great for him
not great for me and I think you're
somewhere in between you enjoy travel
you're gonna go on vacation to Germany
this year you're going to Tokyo this
year those are things that don't appeal
to me as much but if we are traveling
with a purpose like these tour stops add
value to a lot of people's lives then
I'm all for spending that time wisely
and I'm willing to to make that
compromise on the
Travel and even the compromise on public
speaking is I don't actually hate public
speaking it just makes me uncomfortable
not a natural public speaker and same
goes for crowds of people I am an
introvert I don't hate people I just
more comfortable when I'm by myself but
I find the place I grow the most is when
when I put myself into that discomfort
zone and so touring for me in the past
has been a great way for me to grow and
learn a lot of lessons and also for us
to fail a lot so let's let's go back
what five six years Ryan our very first
tour so we started the minimalists 2010
December 14 2010 we started the
minimalist about a year later a little
less than a year later we went out on a
just a minimalist meetup tour we had no
plans our first tour stop was November
of 2011 in st. Petersburg Florida we had
no plans we had no speech prepared and
we just booked like coffee shops and
really small book stores and restaurants
and and we had small meetups as some as
small as two people yeah well it was
nice cuz back then like we could just
feel like hey we're gonna meet at this
coffee shop and would not even really
talk to the coffee shop owner it was
like hey a party of six because it was
us and for the people showing up and so
we could do that and I learned so much
from that that it was a like a year and
a half long tour basically or a
year-long tour we went out in these
little legs where we go out for a week
or two weeks sometimes as much as three
weeks at a time and we just meet at
these clubs and we would we didn't have
any money so we'd often sleep in the car
or we'd sleep our readers houses or
couches or so occasionally we'd spring
for a motel 8 we'd sleep at rest stop
sometimes I remember once we fell asleep
in in Phoenix Arizona outside of Phoenix
between Phoenix and San Diego I woke up
and there's a sign run for the car it's
a beware of scorpions and snakes were
venomous creatures so we've learned a
lot of lessons from that but I also
learned that you know what when we
booked these venues and as the crowds
got larger it became harder and harder
for you and I to book the you and me to
book the venues oh yeah it came to over
holiday happiness torn I remember
booking
that was 27 2012 yeah so like that was
like that was my first taste of oh wow
like when you know that more than six
people are gonna show up yeah
you've got to book these menus and it's
difficult to find a bookstore that can
hold you know 70 you know 150 people and
then we went out 2014 again booked at
ourselves between you me and we you know
had the help of a couple other people we
finally got everything booked but even
then it was like the Indianapolis
experience where 500 people showed up
it's pouring down rain they're waiting
in line and the venue could hold 60
people right so a double-header wouldn't
have even have done it for that stop so
like yeah that was a huge huge learning
for us and now we have Andrew who is
like our saving grace with with booking
what and he's got the the experience we
were just kind of we were waiting we're
amateurs it worked for the time but as
it grew you know the time when I really
realized that this whole thing was
actually going to it was spreading
beyond you know these really small
groups of people it was that holiday
happiness tour so we we have a publicist
who actually lives in Toronto Sarah and
she did a few different things with some
newspapers there and our web site
traffic had been going up and up and up
that those first two years of a web site
and we arrived in Toronto December of of
2012 and we're literal I was sleeping on
Sarah's floor a publicist floor were
alternate you and I are we're sharing
her couch and the floor the loveseat oh
yeah yeah was it what you said I
couldn't I'm six-two man and trying to
fit on a but we were grateful for what
we have we had a blank grateful and we
shared what we had and it had to work
and talk about you know compromising we
just didn't have the money to stay at
hotels back then thankfully now we will
sell tickets to our tours now we can pay
for hotels we can also do really cool
things like we're building an orphanage
with some of the proceeds from the
lessons now tour so the Boston event all
the presale stuff a hundred percent of
the presale is going to build an
orphanage on the US
Mexico border so we can do really cool
stuff with the money as well but we can
also stay in hotels and have our own bed
and be well-rested which is which is a
nice bonus right yeah and we can rent
Lamborghinis way you rented a
Lamborghini
no Sean cancel that reservation yeah so
did you see Sean gonna make a note he
did always joking he's crossed out the
word Lamborghini
yes important thing like when we make
money from stuff like this we don't do
it don't we don't do it to do stuff like
buy a Lamborghini but yeah we will
travel and well also it's a little bit
more comfortable and yeah we make them
more comfortable but allows us to go to
more cities to do that as well anyway
while we were there in Toronto we show
up to this where our event was at a
co-working space if you recall and like
this is gonna give a shout out to Erica
and Melissa yes Erica Melissa definitely
helped us out booked the venue there
they worked in the same building they
booked this co-working space that maybe
fit 80 people and we could probably we
knew we could cram a hundred hundred and
twenty people into the space and the
problem is we show up and there's
another event going on there that night
and there's this line out the door for
this other event and I'm like what is it
our concert going on here or something
and like okay where's Erica like none of
our people are gonna be able to get
anywhere with anticipating 60 80 maybe
even 100 people are gonna show up to
this and they're gonna think they're at
the wrong place because they're at this
other event and so there's this line out
the door and a line up five flights of
stairs to get to the top of where this
co-working space is and we're walking
through it and and finally I'm walking
through all this crowd I look at at
Melissa and I'm like hey what is this
what is this line here what why are all
these people here what other event is
going on tonight why we scheduled this
the same night as our event and she
looks at me with this look like you
[ __ ] these people are here to see you
guys and that that's what I knew like oh
my goodness there are I don't know how
many people were there that night 300
350
yeah hundreds of people
just snaked around the stairwell and
around the building and so we not only
had to do a double header but we had to
find like us up to that point like I
think that was our biggest Oh without a
doubt without a doubt and they were
growing before then but like it sort of
grew exponentially and then from there
you know it continued to grow but we
started doing this when there were two
people showing up so I remember in
Vienna Knoxville the fourth tour stop we
ever did your home your birth city I
should say we showed up no one was there
it's his coffee you're getting ready to
leave yeah we were walking out the door
hey you guys are the minimum lesson I
was so I'm like yes we are yeah and it
was just a couple and it was one of the
best conversations we ever had was a guy
who had lost he fasted for forty days he
had lost hundreds of pounds in doing
that and he was talking about how
minimalism had saved his life literally
saved his life help him refocus on his
health I will never forget oh yeah him
Thomas about that experience cuz what he
was talking about real hunger he's like
you know you don't eat for the first
half of that any like man I'm hungry and
like might even get a little hangry and
he goes and then the second day like you
know it's maybe he still get hungry but
you know after the third or fourth it's
like when you juice fast I guess yeah
yet and yeah long story short he was
like he's like you don't know true
hunger until you haven't eaten in like
30 days yeah yeah yeah it was crazy yeah
apparently like so at some point he he
stopped being hungry but then he hit
that that point once again where he's
like okay my body is eating stuff that
shouldn't be eating and you know
obviously you you don't want to do a
fast like that without assistance from a
doctor or something like that but anyway
yeah so I've learned so much in fact a
lot of lessons we learn we learn what
stories resonated with people while
we're on the tour Ryan we learned what
and that eventually made it into our
book everything that remains it because
we would tell go out on the road and so
just start talking to people all these
stories and the things that really
resonated like the packing party or my
mother is dealing with her sentimental
items for me at first those were just
sort of afterthought so that's in the
past let's just talk about
intentionality let's talk about
decluttering or whatever but it will is
know was like these are true stories
that people resonate
and so a lot of those stories made it
into everything that remains and I
wouldn't have known that had we not gone
out on those tours tour stops with two
to twelve people showing up and allowed
us to have deeper conversations and
that's why in fact with all these events
we're doing the VIP events beforehand
we're just a few dozen people will have
will have access to those people and we
can have more intimate conversations
with them as opposed to doing so I'll
give you an example let's say we're
going to be in Boston on April 15th so
that event starts probably like seven
o'clock or so or the doors open at 7:00
but right around 5:00 p.m. will do a VIP
event for 45 minutes we're going to sit
in a room with that small group of
people and we'll have some discussions
I'm really eager to see what we learn
from those discussions and how we can
move that forward so we'll have some
questions we want to ask them and and
get some dialogue going but we won't
have a whole lot of prepared material
we'll have prepared discussions really
jump off points so we can learn from you
just like we did six years ago we
learned from the audience and we really
grew from that and it allowed us to
create some really great stuff in the
future whether it was everything that
remains or the documentary or whatever
it allows us to create something
beautiful because we incorporated other
people's perspective so if you want to
participate in that process then you
definitely want to get involved with the
presale because usually the VIP event
tickets they go away during during the
pre-sale let's see after the holiday
happiness tour in 2012 Ryan we did 2013
we did two very very small tours like
micro tours
do you remember these we did spring into
minimalism which was like six cities and
we were driving down South by Southwest
with me you and Colin was with us yeah
yeah okay so we did Denver and we did
what else did we do besides Boston we
did Houston we did what yeah yeah yeah
Austin Houston Dallas even right yeah
maybe yeah I remember because we stay
with the family and Fort Worth okay yeah
and then we the thing nellis there was
Missoula we did Missoula six cities and
that was just a short tour we did with
Colin hopefully we get we can drag Colin
around for one or two of these these
tour stops that helped and we'll have
some surprise guest at some of these as
well I'm gonna be reaching out to some
folks who we may have as a super secret
surprise guest and we won't reveal it
until the day they show up and maybe use
some musical act
that was one thing I really like from
the 2014 tour we had some people on big
fans of who were who opened up for us on
on the road and performed music and like
I used to pay to go to their concerts
and now they're there performing with us
and it adds just an extra layer of
beauty to to the event whenever we can
do that we try to make it a special
night for everyone a unique experience
for everyone not just giving a talk or
answer a question that's important but
giving hugs and creating a musical
atmosphere an aesthetic atmosphere of
visual atmosphere for everyone so you
have the best experience and it
hopefully is a catalyst for change in
your life so we did that spring in the
minimalism tour and then we did our
shortest tour ever Ryan the 2013 Alberta
Canada tour I was two cities and we did
Edmonton and Hungary yeah yeah that's
right which was crazy cuz right when we
left Calgary that number the flood hit
yes yeah so was 2013 and it was like two
weeks or a week after that right yeah
and mate we're gonna we're gonna get
back to both of those cities hopefully
for that second leg of the tour
I love Alberta I mean it's like Montana
on steroids especially go out to Banff
speaking speaking of Banff so in 2014 we
did 100 city tour eight countries
hundred and nineteen events we've talked
about that ad nauseam that was crazy a
lot of learnings from that but the next
year 2015 the word tasting tour we did
35 cities but that one was totally
different experience from what we've
done in the past so you and I run a
publishing company with our friend Colin
right called asymmetrical press and we
we drag some of our authors on the road
Shaun mihalick and Josh Wagner and me
and you and Colin was that it was that
six weeks eight weeks how long was it
yeah there's a couple months yeah a
couple months and we did 35 cities but
you and I we divided and conquered that
one because we were kind of done with
touring for a while and so you'd go out
and do a handful of cities and we did a
bunch of like random cities like be do
we do Butte I think we did Butte yep
definitely tube you did oh wait no no no
we didn't do beYOU we did Billings yeah
we did Billings we did
Kalispell yeah his sky's steel hooked it
up with a bamf yeah we did we so obvious
thing in Montana we did
Missoula and Hamilton really ran the
places Great Falls and then we went up
to Canada and did Calgary and Edmonton I
went to those stop you went to all of
Montana stop so I'm going to the Canada
stops and then we drove over my first
time I ever been to Victoria and that
was that wasn't on that yeah I made I
say it's like driving and it was yeah it
was really awesome
I wish I would have more time with anger
but Cecil is out there right yeah yeah
we spent some time with him where I
spent some time with him while I was out
there Paul Jarvis who's a really
talented creator he does some great like
creative class it helps creative people
be more creative I think it's just Paul
Jarvis calm or I'll just put a link to
his name and the show notes a really
great guy he helps creators be more
creative just a wonderful person as well
yeah but he's out there and on Vancouver
Island we went to Vancouver which will
try to get back to Vancouver this year
and no Cooper we wasn't watching right
in a place like he said we went to Banff
that one was weird man I was at that one
and it was eight people showed up its
Banff it's and it was a pop-up show we
did and they were like only eight people
there and there were like eight of us
yeah on tour so we had also had Sky
Steel who created the music a musician
friend of ours he plays he plays a
violin and he sings and he plays guitar
he does a lot of he creates a beautiful
experience he's got the bet so he plays
violin for people who don't know I plays
violin for Vanessa Carlton and the way
that they met is like you're like movie
scenario where Skye was playing in a bar
I think in Hamilton yeah it was in
Hamlet Montana yeah oh wow
playing it up and like I mean Hamilton
Montana just to give you guys some
context what's the population I'm we're
looking up real quick
Hamilton Montana I've had to guess I'm
gonna say 13,000 all right I'm gonna
guess 7,000 it is 4,500 so just to give
you all like a little perspective this
is a town of 4500 people yeah he's
playing in a bar Vanessa Carlton happens
to be there yeah cuz she's got some
family or friends there mm-hmm and like
one up to him afterwards and she was
like you have to go on tour with me yeah
it's funny that you say that man I I saw
Vanessa Carlton in Chicago into tan
November of 2006 and he was it was the
first war he ever went on with her and
he was he was playing violin for her oh
that's awesome it's oh yeah I had no
idea who he was
by the way he doesn't live in Montana he
lives in well he lived in Brooklyn at
the time she lives in Manhattan he was
in Nashville now very talented musician
check out his music wherever you get
fine digital music a sky steel we'll put
a link to that in the show notes as well
but he went on tour with us create this
whole audio landscape this audio
atmosphere the audio aesthetics of
touring I learned a lot about about that
through that process and it was all of
us in a rented van smelling like and
because we have we have a few female
authors but they are far more
responsible than us guys and they
couldn't go on the tour with us because
they have you know actual commitments
and we we've let go of our commitments
and so we we just hit the road for that
period of time something like 35 cities
and we we rotated on and off did some
random cities and and then came back to
Montana but I learned a lot about the
sort of audio experience and creating a
better experience given the resources
you have now some of the venues were
like then Banff was a bar and so people
are talking over you but creating the
bet and by the way that was a even
better experience for someone like Sean
mihalick who's very talented novelist
but doesn't have a lot of experience at
live events because people don't go to
readings that often and so him having to
read at a bar and bam over people
talking invaluable experience oh yeah
because that's it's a it's a failure
it's my definition it's a failure right
but it's not really a failure because
you succeed from that that lesson that
you've learned and then what last year
we went on the documentary tour we did
15 cities over the course of a month or
so it was great and screen the
documentary we did a live version of our
podcast and some of those cities which
you can go back and listen to in our
podcast feed and now this year 2017
we've got two legs of the tour for North
America and if all that goes well we
hope to to make it overseas as well any
closing thoughts here Ryan about about
the tour
anything else you're looking forward to
is there a city you're looking forward
to the most is there a city or
disability
make it two up sir rolls man that
lobster I'm looking for lobster roll
Massachusetts yes my favorite city no
man uh what's the most important what's
the one thing that you bring on tour
that's the most important to you oh yeah
yeah my hairdryer yeah
but actually so in the documentary I've
had so many people ask about what's the
bag that you use and we talked about
this in a previous podcast
it's a Malcolm font II a bag it's no
longer made some in the documentary we
have a little segment document or
packing like the minimalists you can see
a longer version of that video on our
youtube channel youtube.com slash the
minimalist it's called pack like the
minimalist so I packed for ten months in
one carry-on bag Malcolm font a bag so
okay so I guess the bag is probably the
most important thing to bring with you
the back is probably the most important
thing I own yeah okay so inside the bag
uh-huh actually no I guess I guess the
bag that's that's a good answer
here's the thing so Malcolm might be
bringing that bag back xiangqi put a
link to that show I think it's just on
his website he finally got ahold of us
and he's like hey I see a lot of buzz
around this I've had over a thousand
people contact me about that yeah yeah
and he's like he's like if people were
interested have him sign up for this you
know an email or essentially yeah so if
he decides to make it again in the
future he can get all to you he's gonna
make a small like he actually didn't
know this but he told me I was stalking
him on the phone so we meet you and
Colin are on tour on the the spring into
minimalism tour 2013 we all had that
same Malcolm font a bag right there were
three back you over are trone there's
three of that same bag in a trunk right
we had literally exactly one percent of
all bags that were ever made of that bag
oh really he produced only because he
did it as an art project he's produced
only 300 bags oh wow and so he'll
probably do it again in the future and
if he does it'll I don't know if it'll
be limited to 300 or whatever but it
will certainly be limited yeah and by
the way guys you don't need another bag
in your life yeah yeah just so you know
yeah if you're if you think a bag is
going to completely complete you you're
probably wrong now if you're at a stage
real like I just broke my Patagonia bag
I've had it for 14 years I'm now in the
market for another bag it might be a
good bag for you but it may not be a
good fat bag for you as well it's really
up to you to determine whether or not it
wide value to your life yeah anyway so
that was probably the most important
thing
I mean I don't pack a whole lot I had
this pair of pants I'm wearing I'll wear
throughout the entire tour yeah so I
won't I'll pack a pair of shorts to
exercise in I will pack man I'll pack a
few weeks worth of t-shirts weeks worth
underwear weeks worth of socks
unless it's summertime then I'll just
wear a pair of toms with no logos on
them and call it a day man coffee kit
oh yes the most important thing yeah
it's like well even like we're going to
Chicago here soon and for a talk we're
giving we're gonna do some like media
stuff up there yeah but when this comes
out we'll be on be in Chicago when Windy
City live as well oh yeah that's right
but uh but what I was gonna say is like
I know there's awesome coffee in Chicago
uh-huh so I don't necessarily need to
bring the coffee kit but like you know
staying at an Airbnb or a hotel or
something I still need the coffee cake
because like I mean Hotel coffees
alright it's so much nicer man you got
to like good beans someone like yeah I
don't I don't yeah it's it's the one
thing I'm not really embarrassed to
admit I'm addicted to there are worse
things to be addicted to yeah yeah yeah
and so addiction is also a weakness but
but not when it comes to convey all
right Josh let's move on well you know
we usually do actually you know what
we'd love to hear about your experiences
with traveling yeah if you have a
comment or tip about minimalist travel
give us a call for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine or you can also
send us a voice memo now podcast at the
minimalists comm is the email address
you just record a voice memo on your
phone send it over to us we will record
our fit or sorry we will air our
favorite tips and tricks about travel or
touring or whatever your comments are
about today leave us a voicemail send us
a voice memo we will air our favorites
on a following episode upcoming episode
all right Ryan do you want to you want
to move on to right here right now
actually before that added value do you
have anything that's added value to your
life recently yes
every time I'd recommend something
that's over 100 bucks it really I really
feel bad about it but I got the new air
pods uh-huh
GameChanger air pods so let's talk about
our bodies I have a pair as well so air
pods I was gonna reckon
in this last episode but I waited
because I knew you were getting value
thank you I appreciate it for sure so
think of you know the regular earbuds
that come with your iPhone yes you know
there's actually called ear ear pods are
you serious yeah okay so think about the
ear pods that come with your iPhone
remove all the wires mm-hmm and yeah
it's like the first cuz I got I got a
pic cuz when I'm listening to music
whether I'm riding my bike like just to
the store or if I am listening to music
on the plane and I've got the cords I
will inevitably like rip them out of my
ears or like Mariah and I will be
sharing them on the airplane and we're
ripping many of each other's ears right
so yeah long story short like this takes
the chords out and it is the only thing
I don't like about it
uh-huh you can't turn the volume up from
you have to like go to your phone to
turn the volume up not sure now I mean
you can use Siri but dude you can't you
series unavailable on an airplane right
so so it's a little bit in kameda but
because they work so well that's why I
like them it's not I mean the Bluetooth
feature is great but there's stereo
Bluetooth and it has good sound quality
like you haven't you haven't complained
about me being on my ear every time I
call Josh on speakerphone your earphones
he's like Ryan it sounds like you're
skydiving please put me on your regular
phone which is which is fine sound of
skydiving with a sock on your phone yeah
so with these like I've got no
complaints on the microphone and my
actual the the the ear pods yeah yeah my
ear pods actually broke and I was just
getting another pair of ear pods and I
realized that the we're not looking for
my was like oh my god they have like ear
pods without the quartz yeah they're
little eggs eat now Josh that is in a
three version of expensive what does it
breathe mean but at the end of the day
it totally adds value to my life I
really like about them and I am a sucker
for aesthetics but they're like so the
they're they're beautiful but the little
cases that you put the storage case
which I have in my pocket right here let
me pull it out it's in my pocket here we
go
so I'm holding this this white little it
looks like a flawless pack right in fact
Ella has confused it as flaws she likes
to play with floss although we've
stopped her from play she pretends floss
as a snake and but when I open it it
yeah it charged it shows you the charge
yeah and but then when I remove the
earPod and this or the right one is on
the right side so it's very
aesthetically pleasing when I take it
out my ear when I put it my ear it's
gonna make a little sound boom yeah and
so and then when I put it back in here
there's the most satisfying little
little clip let me see if I can get this
on the mic it like it clicks into place
that is so satisfying and then when I
close the cover same thing oh it is so
satisfying 1 2 3 it is I mean my all of
my OCD needs have been met today just by
these these air pods and this is not an
advertisement we don't you all know we
don't do advertisements right we refuse
to take money for advertising we've had
we we've turned down tens of thousands
if not hundreds of thousands of dollars
for advertisements because they don't
align I don't want to have to recommend
something just because I have to
recommend it and so I can't recommend
something like this and I've been trying
it for a while I've gotten a lot of
value from it everyone I've talked to
have used it has enjoyed it as well what
do you have to say to all the conspiracy
theorists out there who are like you
guys are just trying to indoctrinate us
with Apple products yeah well some
conspiracies are true this question no
III have no brand loyalty I think brand
loyalty is a sign of weakness yeah yeah
I have things that are useful high
quality and I really enjoy them then and
so like Apple has a their their writing
program called pages I've used that in
the past but I used their better
programs now so I googled I use Google
Docs and I you I but I love you know the
thing I write in most now is actually
the Apple memo pad but if something else
comes along better I don't have brand
loyalty brand loyalty actually weakens
the product our friend cuts right talks
about actually that's why Apple has
their quality has kind of decreased over
the last several years for certain
products especially was like certain
software things are there yeah or
they're trying to like appeal to the
masses
and therefore the features that were
once useful to people who had a specific
use are no longer there so they can
appeal to the masses yeah anyway yes the
air pods add immense value to my life -
thanks for recommending that Ryan I have
only three recommendations let's see
here actually I'll just give two of
these since we're talking about tour
waves I got that idea waves from John
Mayer so he's putting he put out an
album this year he just put out the
second wave of this album it's called
the search for everything wave - I don't
like it as much as the first wave I love
the first wave really dig that second
wave and it's it's the one of the songs
when there was very Montana the second
song on there I think it's called like a
wave emoji or something anyway
wave 2 of searched for everything by
John Mayer get that wherever you get
digital music and then every time I see
on our tour page future legs yes it
cracks me up I don't know I'm just
picturing like Bionic legs or something
I need to hurry up and wrap this up
because I have to go to the bathroom so
bad all right another podcast I've been
listened to a lot recently the Craig
Groeschel leadership podcast if you lead
an organization or a group of people or
you're an aspiring leader he leads a
whole bunch of churches and the Oklahoma
area now I am NOT a religious person
personally but it is a secular podcast
and in terms of he's a great leader and
uses great strategies to lead other
people in an effective but also moral
way in a way that will align with your
values and help you be a more effective
leader we'll put a link to that in the
show notes as well move on real quick -
right here right now Ryan a few things
that are going on our good friend Matt
dia Vela is producing a web series
called making minimalism he's the
director of our documentary which is
called minimalism a documentary about
the important things he's going behind
the scenes of that documentary it's all
free you can find it on his website Matt
Diavel accom slash minimalism we'll put
a link to that in the show notes as well
also every Monday from March 6 through
April 10th and including April 10th we
are doing Monday's with the minimalists
on Facebook live and Instagram live we
just did our first session this week
it's
two p.m. Eastern Time every Monday we're
gonna answer your questions we'll talk
about what's going on in the lives of
the minimalists and yeah we actually I
really loved what we did I don't know if
we'll keep that format up maybe we'll
change it up a bit but we were driving
around town and that was it was so fun
to answer questions well don't worry I
wasn't looking at the phone Sean was was
looking was holding the phone and asking
us questions and you and I just got to
drive around and sort of have
conversations and it was like what's
that Jerry Seinfeld thing since I sound
like Jerry Seinfeld apparently he does
coffee in cars with comedians or
something oh yeah yeah so it's like that
but without comedians without coffee no
I need coffee oh you didn't have coffee
yeah I'm gonna have to have a coffee
next time - that's good call let's do
that next time so yeah join us Monday's
with the minimalist every Tuesday March
6 through April 10th 2 p.m. Eastern also
I'm teaching a one day writing workshop
online it's called how to write better
seats are limited I think to the first
300 people it's online it's a very
attenuated version of my four week
writing class you can find both of those
and how to write better dot-org I want
to help you write better business emails
better books better blog post I just
want to help you write better and I
think I can do that just by breaking
down my recipe how I learned to write
better and find ways to give those
ingredients to you so you can create
your own recipe for better writing all
right we've been talking to the whole
time about the tour so I'm not going to
talk any more about that just go to the
mentalists calm slash tour for tickets
and cities also this month I'm doing a
daily Instagram essay every day posting
a beautiful photo and an essay with that
photo over at the minimalist Instagram
account it's just at the minimalists and
that's all I got right now Ryan you got
anything else for us yeah man here I got
some of this here it's brand-new shiny
voice mail comments and tips from our
listeners and I'm on my way back in
California where I spent some time with
my cousin and we watched the minimalist
movie my third time seeing it but her
first time seeing it she needed to see
it
but you know it John Donne me that I
have three children and the oldest is 33
and the youngest is 24 and I have two
grandchildren eighteen months and one
month boys and I have a great networking
community of friends now and also when
my kids were growing up and I just
watching your movie the third time it
made me think about how many times I
said to my friends how can we slow down
you know we want to do something we
don't have the time to do it we're
constantly behind we're trying to think
ahead or trying to prepare for the
future and it it was a it was a question
that came up continuously while my kids
were growing up about how to slow down
how to live how to have a light and you
know after watching your movie - the
third time I finally saw the answer I
really believe the answer was that we
all just had too much stuff our kids had
too much stuff and and by stuff I just
mean belongings things we had to
maintain things we had to do and I think
that if it if we could have known then
what I know now I think of our lives
would have been so much different and we
would have been able to see the forest
for the trees we would have been able to
see how we could have slowed down and
had coffee with each other you know in
the morning and not feel like you know
we had to clean our house or we
you know had to run out and do this
errand or get this or get that but we
already have a job we already had 20 so
my name is Hannah and I live in
Altamonte Springs Florida hey guys I
just wanted to share kind of a neat
story I have a friend who just started a
shoe making business where he makes
custom leather boots and he offered to
make me a pair for free because I was
his friend and had helped him out with
some things in the past well at the time
we live in Michigan and since then I've
moved to Florida so completely I've been
listening to your podcast and it caused
me to rethink boots situation it just
doesn't make any sense for me to own a
pair of Austin awesome custom-made hand
boots that I will rarely ever wear
living in Florida it would make a lot
more sense for someone in Michigan to
have them where they'll be worn all the
time so I talked to my friend and
fortunately he hadn't started making my
boots yet so I asked him if instead he
would make them for someone else and he
said that he actually had someone in
mind that he knew was in need and would
really appreciate them so even though it
hurt a little bit to give away a really
amazing pair of high quality handcrafted
shoes which are technically minimalism
friendly it still didn't make any sense
for me to own them as they wouldn't
genuinely add much value to my life by
sitting on the floor getting dusty all
year instead they're going to be
blessing from one else who will be
genuinely enjoying them so it's a
win-win-win for me my friend and the
person who will be getting the pair of
boots hey Joshua and Ryan this is Adam
from Massachusetts thank you both so
much for all that you do to help
simplify and add value to people's lives
I have a few digital tools that have
helped me reduce the traffic of messages
and lists we so often lose or perhaps
missing
on a daily basis the first is Google key
which is a sticky note application to
help you add dates and times to remind
you of upcoming tasks that may not
warrant a calendar invite such as
dropping off a letter or even making
grocery lists the notes can be archived
when they're done so it's less of an
inbox look to it although the archives
can be searched at a later time if need
be the second tool is called unroll em
II which is an email service for most
common email providers and it shows you
every list to which your email is
currently associated once you give the
service permission to access your email
I've used this service for years by the
way and I've had no negative experiences
with it and it's free you can
unsubscribe from any and all lists
they're on this single site or you can
choose to keep them in your inbox and
lastly you can quote roll them up into a
single daily email from the unrolled
that Emmy famous perhaps the coolest of
all is that it shows you when you're
added to new email lists so that it's a
sustainable resource to add to your life
the last tool is more of a shift in
behavior with respect to digital
activity so recently I removed all non
value-adding applications and push
notifications from my phone and I began
doing all of my major work assignments
first thing in the morning at work as
opposed to checking emails both of these
behavior switches have added tremendous
time to my life for valuable activities
and output in both professional and
personal capacities anyways I hope that
these tips helped your listeners as
theirs have helped me in the past as
well alright so that's it for this
episode if you have a question for the
minimalists give us a call for zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine and
if you leave here with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green oh I bet that you'll
be fine without
[Music]
every little thing that you got a hand
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for you got a grand oh I bet
that you'll be fine without your team
[Music]
you
[Music]